والمشكله بعد اذا سمح لي بمثابه في مثال
كتاب توبي ان الباحثين العرب وهم ياخذون
منه يا ليت اخذوا منه بعقلانيه في حاله
كسل يعني غريبه انا بضرب بثالث طريف ذكرت
في ورقتي هو ذكر شخص اسمه عبد الجليل
بالانجليزي كتب عبد الجليل
المعروفه لما قرات الاسم يعني انا ابن انا
ابن البيئه
اسمها
دورت دورت اخر شيء طلع
في شيخ انت ما الى حزب عفوا انتبه الى خط
الامام غير مشيئه سواء كان يحضر دروس
الخميني في النجف اسمها عبر الجليل ابن
مرهون الماء مرهون الماء ولان الاسماء
المركبه عاده
يحذف واحد منها الشوط الاول باعتبار ان
عائله في عده عوائل في القطيف فالناس
السميع عبد الجليل للماء اختصاره توبي
يقابل ناس كثيرين سمع اسم عبد الجليل
للماء كتبها بالانجليزي في كذا واحد كتبها
نفس الشيء بعد نقطه اخرى همم
كثير من روايات اللي فيها نوع من الطائفيه
همم والتعبئه ضد الشيعه تذكر اسم واحد
اسمه همم ضابط ايراني اسمه احمد شريف تدور
منه هذا احمد شريف
اا امر له علاقه بشيء بالشيعه في بلد مثل
المملكه
يطلع شخصيا ما احد يعرف